bonjour bonjour à tous bienvenue sur des
gonades tv pour la troisième partie de
ce championnat du monde de cars celle
anand
après donc la victoire de car senna de
seconde partie alan dale de nouveau les
blancs est ce qu'il va être capable de
revenir au score et de jouer plus son
style donc base est quand même sur une
meilleure préparation de nos ouvertures
et sans doute un milieu plus plus tendue
alors que carsen lui est très très fort
dans tout ce qui est finale avec la
possibilité qu'il a qui est quand même
assez extraordinaire de jouer un peu
comme capablanca un peu cette capacité
de jouer des finales où ils accumulent
des petits avantages pour finir par
l'emporter de façon systématique alors à
noter que dans la deuxième partie pour
revenir sur cette partie gagnée par
carsen son anti berlin ce coup détroit
aurait été joué
à son époque par steinitz le premier
champion du monde le champion du monde
de 1886 et steinitz qui avait lui aussi
d'ailleurs influencé bobby fischer d'un
bobby fischer dans son livre mes
soixante meilleurs partis bien avait
joué des débuts notamment eu des
coupures yeux comme cavalier h3g pas si
ceux qui connaissent ou ceux qui
connaissent pas encore il faut aller
voir mais parce qu'évidemment faut lire
les 60 meilleures parties de bobby
fischer qui l'a aussi été inspiré par ce
tennis donc il semblerait que voilà ce
tennis soit une des champions du monde
qui inspire car scène comme il a pu
inspirer
bobby fischer c'est possible en tout cas
voilà il a joué nantis berlin qui
transposé dans une finale qui comprenait
sans doute mieux que canada lors que va
faire un an maintenant avec les blancs
c'est ça qui va nous intéresser
aujourd'hui bien sûr dans cette partie
numéro trois combats donc voir ici c'est
parti pour un an avec le coût des quatre
donc d4 le même couple à la première
partie carsen réitère qu'alexis même
coup ses 4 est là qu arsène avait joué
dans la première souvenez vous il avait
joué ce pion g7 ici en g6 donc il avait
joué cette ouverture avec l'idée
derrière de jouer la grüne fais c'est à
dire le coût des 5 suivi du fou en g7
avec ici le fion kétou c'était la
première partie mais là car scène on va
voir varie d le deuxième coup voilà qu
arsène qui cherche pas à l'ancienne en
quelque sorte end à imposer son
ouverture mais a varié plus tôt à varier
les possibilités parce que ce qui
intéresse car scène c'est d'avoir un
milieu de jeux jouables et d'entrer dans
les finales un peu technique voilà donc
c'est pas tellement l'ouverture qui
l'intéressent alors qu'annecy à nantes
s'est essayée par l' avantage
l'ouverture donc on va voir ce qui va se
passer maintenant sur cette nouvelle
ouverture proposé par car ces câbles f3
classic des cinq on rend dans une gamme
vidas qu'avait laissé trois fosses est
normal fourcade donc déjà c'est un choix
d'un mandat il joue pas à fond j'ai cinq
le coût qui est là aussi et classique la
foulée 5 c'est jouable
bien sûr il joue pas non plus au lieu de
fouet 4 il aurait pu jouer le 3 tout de
suite le pion ici en trois le problème
de fond de joux pi3 tout de suite c'est
que ça bouffe le fou mais ça permet de
rouler très vite et on retarde le
développement du phocéen
ça existe aussi il faut être catherine
autre idée on va voir quelle est l'idée
d'un an d'après petit rock ou trois
c'est l'heure puisque maintenant que les
noms évoqués
bon ben on joue et 3 pour finir son
développement avec le fou à noter que ce
fou mais non contrôler ces quatre ans
quatre prises maintenant c'est le fou
qui reprend et après on va on par ok
donc regarder comment les champions de
développent toutes leurs pièces
le problème des noirs d'instituts
d'ouverture et n'en faut pas l'oublier
c'est le fou ces huit ici qui est
enfermé puisqu'il est bloqué derrière
ses propres pions ici donc les noirs en
général et c'est de le développer en
jouant le coup b6 et le jouan bessette
voir en a six ce qui est plus long mais
bon on reste en ligne on ne peut pas
tout faire à la fois donc qu'à aller 17
voilà donc c'est fini un pour ce fou
pour sortir par là c'est mort déjà
c'était mort avec le 6 et maintenant
elle qui a aidé c'est encore plus donc
les coûts b 6e fou besset devoir x 6
plus tard sont envisageables ces 5
alors ça c'est un coup responsables
demandent ils rentrent dans une variante
particulière c'est sain qui laisse
tomber la pression au centre le pion des
cinq qui était en prise potentiel du pur
c4 en jouant ses seins qui joue pour une
expansion elle dame
voilà qu'a prévu car celle là dessus on
va voir ses 6 alors normal pourquoi
parce que le noir peuvent pas envisager
b6 tout de suite pour qui permettrait
d'attaquer le ton ces 5 et 2
paré la sortie du fou à cause de 6,6 qui
pourraient être envisagées par les
blancs et ovales cavaliers s'il revient
mais 8 on peut jouer cavalier en 5 puis
après on peut protéger ce pion par tour
c'est un sans doute est ce pion c6 est
un poison est dans le camp noir
donc attention donc il joue d'abord ces
six pour bloquer ici le plus ancien le
problème de ces six évidence et qu'on
voit tout de suite c'est que le foot
c'est vite et entièrement derrière ses
pions les pions sont sur la même couleur
que le fou et on voit que ça c'est
gênant pour le développement c'est le
problème des noirs dans ce type
d'ouverture évidemment fou des trois
magnifiques fou c'est sa meilleure case
il vise à la fois le camp noir et ll
dame
il a une deux belle diagonale d'action
se fout c'est sans doute la meilleure
place pour son développement
b 6 on attaque le pion c5 les north très
content que les blancs prennent en d6
puisque cela éloignerait un pion qui est
quand même proche du centre le pion
c'est celle qui contrôle la caisse des
six une case même qui plus que dans le
centre les avancées dans 15 mois et si
ce pion s'en va on reprend du pied droit
et les blancs les noirs ont ramené un
pion vers le centre et philidor nous le
dire est que c'est une bonne opération
pour les noirs voilà donc on ne fait pas
bien sûr avec les blancs c'est pas
l'idée des blancs c'est pour ça qu'on a
joué ses cinq combats le voir tout de
suite en ayant préalablement sorti le
fou est sorti le cavalier pourquoi parce
qu'on a connecté dames et tours
quel rapport on va le voir tout de suite
après b 4 à 5 à 3 et force et on garde
le contrôle est maintenant en cas de
prise prise tout reprend tour
heureusement on peut reprendre
évidemment tout ça tombe à l'eau si on
n'a pas sorti à la fois le fou et
lecavalier
donc ça faut l'avoir bien en tête pour
pour ceux qui veulent jouer ce genre de
début ça a c'est un thème qui arrive
souvent cette possibilité de jouer ces
cinq dans d'autres ouvertures aussi je
crois que ça existe aussi dans la carro
cannes d'ailleurs mais donc il faut bien
faire attention que la tour soit
connecté avec la dame sans quoi tout
tombe à l'eau une erreur que font
souvent les débutants ils jouent les
sept cette idée là en oubliant que
après prise prise il ya un vis-à-vis
tout retour donc attention donc x 6
voilà regardez maintenant ce fou qui
avait un problème de sortir comme on
l'avait dit souvent il sort avec b6 ou
allemands baissaient tu sois là c'est
bien on à la tour en huit ans la six et
là c'est les changes de forcer parce
qu'on va pas enlever le fou si on enlève
le fou c'est fini on pourra plus rauque
et donc là c'est pas une bonne idée donc
on va pas enlever ce fou blanc on
pourrait laisser les noirs prendre en d3
mais on va prendre soi-même en a six
puisque après tout reprend 1,6 on peut
considérer que la tour ici à six est mal
placée puisque qu'est ce qu'elle fait en
a6 elle n'est pas protégée elle est en
l'air comme on dit est bon elle est
bloquée par ses propres pions ici
d'ailleurs à noter que ces ses pions
sont dans la même structure que ceux de
hollande dans la deuxième partie
il avait des problèmes avec ses pions là
si vous vous rappelez mien bon c'est pas
du tout la même partie mais on a ce même
schéma
les pions d'avancé et peuvent être
s'avérer gênant est mal placée bon
encore faut-il savoir à en profiter
donc la regarde et riches ou les coudes
à nantes des 5 alors ça c'est un coup
étonnant ça c'est un coup étonnant parce
que ça ça donne un pion le plan b c'est
parce que après le coup de carsen à
prendre d'essai s'est promenée 5 pardon
qui forçait sinon la tour est attaqué on
prenait ses six avec attaque du cavalier
on a gagné un pion parce que si on prend
on reprend ici en bessin eh bien
regardez les noirs se venge sur le pion
c5 et sont très contents des changes est
un pion de l'ale contre un pion central
après prise bureau prend soin du
cavalier seul du fou et les noirs ont
une très belle position avec deux pions
contraint au centre non non c'est pas
envisageable pour les blancs ça peut pas
être l'idée d'un non c'est pas possible
c'est pas de reprendre en bessin
regardez c'est plus joli pouf c6 très
jolie c6 j'attaque c6 et regardez je
vise la casse ces sept avaient pourquoi
parce que je suis protégé par ce fou
d'où l'idée que cette possibilité de
jouer ces scènes tout ça est en
conjonction avec ce fou et f4 software
4control a cassé cette et c'est toute
l'idée d'un land
voilà c'est une très jolie variante très
jolie préparation dame s'est vite alors
c'est une des faces indirecte en cas de
prise du cavalier regarder la dame se
vengerait
enlevez cette flèche la bonne la dame
ici se vengerait sur le canal et ses 3
par transparence prise simplement d'adam
prendre car les échecs
ensuite on reprend le pion 17 et les
noirs n'ont plus aucun problème c'est
pas l'idée d'un angle là non plus c5 et
c7 pardon c'est cette rue protégé par le
fonds et regarder plus tard le cavalier
il aura une belle occasion b5 pour
attaquer enfin protéger le pion ces sept
on va voir que ça tout de suite
c'est l'idée après bay 4-2 carsen qui
est logique le kavé le pion étant
attaqué bombay il vaut mieux jouer
beckham c'est quand même plus dangereux
c'est pal il faut les blancs peuvent pas
prendre en plus ce pion puisqu'en cas de
prise vallori fou prend les quatre
lecavalier ici serait cloué et derrière
le quatrième six viendrait en quatre
voies la cavale et f6 en quatre
attaquants une nouvelle fois le cavaly
c3 avec un gain pour les noirs face il
ya tout qui tombe donc c'est pas l'idée
donc ici c'est pas l'idée d'aller
regarder un an de balès le pion pouf
calais b 5 très joli à regarder ce
cavalier
il est magique ils contrôlent ces sept
donc il rajoute du contrôle qui est déjà
contrôlée par le fou ici ce pion est
très bien défendu c'est le premier point
le deuxième point c'est que ce ce
cavalier il pas délogeables regarder que
ce soit ce cavalier là qui est à 4 cases
de la quasi six heures avant de pouvoir
attaquer ça et en plus on sait pas d'où
on va le faire et il lui aussi les très
loin on pourrait attaquer ce cavalier
via la casse des six forêt faire qu'à
lui qui avait des six mais c'est pas
possible puisque le fou et le cavalier
contrôle de qualité indélogeable c'est
ça qu'il faut retenir
il est très difficile de déloger sky il
est donc très puissant voilà donc
cavalier dans le camp
noir on peut pas l'attaquer mais le pion
b6 empêche les noirs de l'attaqué via
les colonnes voilà sept tours là pour
l'instant peut rien faire donc on va
voir la suite regardez à 4 très joli et
donc car c'est n'aurait pu envisager
aussi de prendre le pion à 3 c'est une
possibilité
dans ce cas là on aurait très
certainement fait le grand roque
enfin l'europe par deux le petit rock
pardon puisqu'ici la menace évidemment
c'était fou mais quatre échecs d'accord
et ce pion à 3 c'est pas très grave
parce qu'on peut le reprendre quand on
veut il n'est pas protégé par la torah 6
à cause du plomb à 5 donc c'est un pion
qui dans le camp blanc
n'est pas une vraie menace et ça va nous
permettre de nous développer par exemple
par damas quatre dames d'avenir par
exemple aura quatre c'est une
possibilité
on protège de calais b 5 on développe la
dame
on va mettre la tour eiffel en c1 c'est
hyper protégé ça et on prend un espion
quand on veut voilà y compris si
pourquoi pas par le cavaliere trois ans
pourrait venir
imaginez qu'à aller des deux cas les
bailleurs et hop on prend à 3 en
surprotégeant lecavalier v5
voyez donc prendre à trois sa part une
bonne solution je gobe des pions sauf
que je suis en fait tu étouffé par les
noirs ici un par la pièce ce magnifique
cavalli b5 qui est superbe
donc c'est pas l'idée de carsen carsen a
trouvé une autre idée qui est sans doute
une bonne défense qui est une contre
attaque c'est tout souvent la
contre-attaqué de la bonne défense à
quatre très joli alors c'est quoi lit de
la cat
mais sûr on avance le pion à montrer
bien mais vous voyez ce pion à elle
bloquée par pure à 3 donc est ce que
c'est ça l'idée non l'idc d'activer
cette tour comme on l'a dit elle était
mal placé en a six l'avenir à 5 pour
chatouiller ce qu'à valider cinq
châteaux dix cavaliers ou vallée ce
cavalier
voilà c'est ça l'idée de 400 s'est posé
des questions ce cavalier qui sinon est
une pièce extrêmement pénible alors à ne
se laisse pas démonter ont regardé très
jolie tranquille
rien à [ __ ] des pions sur le côté pouf
tour ces sommes quand même voilà je
surprotège le pion c7 qui est défendue
maintenant trois fois adams et 8
elle n'est pas prête de partir de ces
huit faut rester bloqué la voilà donc on
surprotège le pion ces sept là lors
l'avantagent toujours de la
surprotection ces deux
de libérer les pièces sur les pièces
belges peuvent peuvent bouger tour c'est
un très joli
alors on pourrait envisager avec les
noirs le coutour à 5 ici qu'est ce qui
se passe sur 3,5 maintenant parce que
c'est pas une idée alors on est moins
inquiet de pour but pour on peut bouger
le cavalier puisqu'on est on à
surprotéger le pion ces sept on peut
envisager deux coups soit fou des six
qui contre attaque sur le fou et en cas
de prise on reprend du cavalier très
intéressant où la deuxième encore plus
simple mais encore peut-être plus
radicale ces câbles et des six que font
les noirs fou prend des six est
envisageable fou prend des 6 et regardez
ce fou non ils attaquent à la fois la
tour et fuites et le pion b4 et il est
pas mal ce fou aussi et on prendrait du
fou puisque on garde le pion à a3 et
comme ça ses pions là sont totalement
neutralisé tandis que l'option c7
devient continuer à être très fort voilà
ça c'est une possibilité simple et on
pouvait aussi envisagé ici le coût
direct après tour à simple donc
voilà après tour à cinq on pouvait aussi
envisager le coup fourré 6 c'est encore
autre chose on laisse le cavalier
emprise alors là pour prendre des cinq
est quasiment forcé parce que sinon bah
là il ya une perte en des six ans sans
rien et si on prend du fou le fou si on
prend du fou cavale et prend la dame est
attaqué et après on fait d'armes donc
voyez c'est une contre attaque souvent
une bonne défense la contre attaque
donc en cas de prise ici simplement
regarder fou prend 2,7 d'accord et la
torre fuite est attaqué et aussi le pion
à 4 donc c'est chaud que font les noirs
si les noirs jouent tour 8 qui est
envisageable
on peut regarder jouer magnifique
variante apprend des quatre tours prend
1,7 et là regardez c'est très joli temps
prend 1,4
là tout est perdu magnifique magnifique
roanne elle peut pas bouger
alors voyez que vous pouviez ce genre de
varane faut que ça soit très bien
préparé donc magnifique préparation d' à
nantes c'est pas simple de se trouver
des solutions car chaîne joue sans doute
un des meilleurs coups cavalier 4 très
bien on s'entraîne le cavalier ce
cavalier en plus pourra être protégé par
l'autre ce cavalier est très bien placé
pourquoi parce que il peut envisager de
venir en c3 et changer ce fameux calais
des cinq dont on a vu qu'il était trop
dangereux
et aussi il a l'oeil sur des six dont on
a vu que c'était une case sensible à
cause des menaces ou des six voir
cavaler 10,6 mais l'anc la tour en c1
protège ses sets cela c'est pas bon
on continue la très jolie coup
d'attendre dans cette position et si on
regarde et cavalli gsm alors ça c'est
très désolant ce coût d'un an
alors l'idée de cavale et g5 est la
suivante c'est que si les noirs prennent
le cavalier par exemple avec leurs
cavaliers d'accord on peut envisager
simplement fou prend cavaliers pourquoi
parce qu'après fou prend fou qui a l'air
de gagner une pièce toujours pareil cas
les des six le pion c'est cette protégée
par la tour la dame de bouger et a
précédemment et donc les blancs auront
gagné au minimum si ce n'est plus
d'ailleurs parce qu'on voit pas comment
sur dame si la tour prend il y aura tout
reprendre avec échec et la dame noire
sera perdue donc ça gagne tout en fait
voilà donc vous voyez que ce cavalier
n'est pas un et pas prenable en fait ou
alors il est prenable mais une seule
fois pour eu simplement faire fou prend
par exemple si c'est ça c'est possible
fo prend g5 et dans ce cas là simplement
fou pranger scène et on peut pas
reprendre du câble et non plus à cause
de calais disent d'accord
et là maintenant le problème c'est que
si le fou noir a disparu des six est
plus faible donc est plus faible pardon
plus et donc on peut envisager des fous
au 7 ou des fous et f4 pour revenir
protéger ses 7es appris plus tard on
jouera f3 et il faudra que les noirs
fasse quelque chose contre le cavalier
b5 sinon ces câbles et des six est
terminée voyez donc c'est très puissant
soucoupe obligé 5
bien que lequel ils sont en prise il est
imprenable donc là car scène joue car
les df 6 il veut sur contrôler ou quatre
pour garder un oeil sur il a compris que
la caisse des six était essentiel cavale
et prend hélas car les prends un cadre
de carsen logique on garde un oeil sur
la caisse des six normales f3 d'un angle
on chasse le défenseur et là on n'a pas
le choix il va falloir contre-attaqué
avec les noirs parce que si on laisse
partir ce qu'à lyon on l'a vu food et 6
voire même cavale et des 6 et on a des
gros gros gros soucis parce que
même sur calais décisif où prendre fou
prend la tour est attaqué et un oeil
on va reprendre b4 avec une position
très très très confortable mais
peut-être même food et si c'est encore
plus fort et voir archi gagnant donc f3
que faire si on s'en bat c'est mon bébé
il faut contre-attaqué classique défense
par contre attaque jeu contre attaque
sur le cavalier b5
j'ai pas le temps de jouer calais des
six puisque l'asse serait cavalli proche
du père une pièce donc la nabe a fait le
plus logique
regardez elle prend le 4 pour prendre
les 5 et d'un point à 4 faut pas oublier
que ben cette tour maintenant ben voilà
le protège plus à 4 donc on a éliminé un
des pions regarder un des pions
dangereux parce que c'était quand même
c'est des pions dangereux ses pions sur
l'ale mais on commence à en éliminer un
déjà du côté blanc par exemple si on
arrive à éliminer tous ses pions et
qu'on reste avec ce qu'ils ont de plus
énorme ans et 7
autant dire que c'est foutu donc il faut
que les noirs garde des possibilités de
contres juin donc garder au moins un
pion passé de ce côté là
sinon c'est mort torah 5 c'est bien on a
à la tour 1 à 5
on va sans doute prendre avec le pion
aux missions à 3,6 une tour protège à 2
à 1 menace on a un semblant de contre
attaque mais dame b 6 dames c6 pardon
toujours pareil toujours sur la colonne
ses jeux sur protège ses 7 et en même
temps j'ai un oeil sur le plan b 6 donc
qu'est ce qui se passait là et alors la
menace
blanche peut aussi sur pions sur dame
prend b6 on attaque aurait aussi la tour
et puis après il peut y avoir des d'un
v8 des choses comme ça voire tout
simplement enfin le pion baisserait mal
à avancer donc là car scène veut
absolument garder un pion passée donc il
fait puis on prend à trois jolis coups
puis on prend à 3 alors là l'idée des
noirs maintenant pourrait être de 10
rebonds mais après je l'éliminé ce pion
ici à 4 puis je vais jouer tour à 8
pourquoi pour surprotéger la casse et 8
sensible et j'ai une tour en défense de
mon pion à l'eiblen aussi une tournée
femmes impures sait mais du coup il ya
un pion pas ses protégés soutenu par une
tour des deux côtés on peut encore tenir
mais anne ans ne laisse pas faire puis
on prend des 5
ok je me dis tu veux venir à 8 mais
maintenant tu fais quoi parce que puis
on prend des cinq si tu prend du plomb
bas et puis on d5 est faible tu pourras
jamais venir à 8 protéger ses huit
passes que je vais prendre ça et le plan
b si cette attaque et aussi donc ce pion
sera toujours faible et si tu fais comme
carsen le seul coup qui semble encore
jouable l'autre coup qui sont encore
jouable si on fait tout reprendre et
c'est bon c'est bien on a pas isolé un
pion au centre le pion ici je prends des
aurait été un pion isolé mais on peut
plus revenir très vite
et oui on peut pas tout avoir donc on
n'a pas affaibli ses pions somptueux
landais mais on n'a plus la possibilité
torah 8 qui libérait la dame parce que
cette dame pour l'instant les blocs et
on s'est vite pourrait faire et là
maintenant on en profite
ouv tranquille on gobe le pion à noter
comme les ici les
les blancs autour par ok alors en
éthique le coup d'avant les blancs les
noirs auraient pu faire un fou et cafu b
4 échecs intermédiaire mais c'est pas
très grave on nous rejoue effroi f2 et
honoraires hockey à la main ensuite avec
la tour comme dit l'autre à la main avec
2,30 qu'il est noir et blanc risqueriez
les noirs n'ont rien ne peuvent pas
attaquer les blancs donc la dame des
sept voiliers que 1 carsen voit bien que
saddam quand même pas du tout activant
ses huit il veut la remplacer par une
tour en bloqueurs ne peut pas encore
plus et ses 8 à noter que dame b 8 qui
propose tout reprend qui on prend avec
dame ne marche pas tout simplement parce
qu'on joue tour c'est 8
simplement on ne prend pas la dame bien
entendu donc dan 17 petit rock voilà on
se précipite pas à jouer des coups non
termine le développement on avait une
tour à sion qui jouait pas il faut
qu'elle joue sept tours voilà elle est
là maintenant elle n'est pas encore en
jeu tout à fait mais déjà un peu plus à
l'est vers le centre l'euro est à l'abri
et on peut envisager mêlant que 7 tours
par exemple jouent sur la colonne c1 c2
c3 c4 n'importe où et ensuite jouer sur
la colonne c'est possible venir en jeu
sur les colonnes à cb ou à aider ses
camarades tour ses huit de la part des
noirs donc il faut bloquer à ce pioncer
qui à tout moment menace de faire des
dames avec des possibilités de
combinaisons et la regarder très joli
coup pour ces six pour viser la classe
des six empêcher food et 6 à noter le
coup d'avant regardez ici les noirs
pouvaient envisager food et 6 pour
rajouter de la pression sur ses sept
éliminer ce fut f4 qui est monstrueux il
est superbe se foutent contrôler ses
sept pions passer à une casse de
promotion mais ça ça marche pas ça
marche pas pourquoi mais simplement
regarder fou prend confort et dans ce
cas-là tout reprend avec les noirs ce
qui semble logique
on attaque la dame il faut que les
blancs jouent et puis après on va
pouvoir jouer tour s'est vite par
exemple
mais non on n'a pas le temps est ce qu
ont simplement fait d'armes est oui
on fait dames ont fait là maintenant sur
d'emprunt dame bas est simplement faux
les dames prend tout regarder dans une
tour de plus surtout reprend dame avait
simplement forêt tout reprend échec dans
prend d'emprunt tour et là aussi on a
une tour de plus donc on a perdu une
pièce
donc on ne peut pas ici dans cette
position avec les noirs jouer food et 6
mai après tour ses huit ont peu parce
que maintenant on a bloqué le pion on
peut menacer entre guillemets faut des
six non plus travis iman temps donné que
les blancs contre le très bien la
colonne c mais en jouant tour c6 on
enlève en plus cette possibilité au noir
contrôler la casse d'ici là car scène
joue le coup g5 qui est logique
j'attaque loup blanc où il va et en plus
je me menace je me ménage pardon une
case pour le roi angers 7 de façon à
pouvoir l'extraire en cas de match du
couloir le fameux échec du couloir là
pour l'instant on était quand même pris
derrière nous pillons donc là ça permet
de se libérer tout en gagnant du temps
sur le fou fou g3 pourquoi pas à
continuer par h5 il aurait pu ici à le
carsen essayer de menacer h4 ou mal fou
en 5 f 6 et est perdu mais sur 4
simplement les blancs ont rejoué h trois
essais terminés h4 pour les noirs ou h 2
bon il aurait pu quand même tenté ça
pour essayer de mettre le roi blanc sous
pression c'est possible mais il n'a pas
choisi ça car c'est ni ajout à notre
coin sont intéressants foulée 4 encore
une pièce entreprises mais évidemment on
peut pas laisser les noirs prendre la
tour c 6 donc aller en prise sans être
en prise à des emprises mais on a aussi
une pièce qu'il faut garder à l'oeil la
tour c 6 alors fou des cas de menaces
entre guillemets quand même une
possibilité qui est quand même fou des
deux parce que fout des deux attaques le
point 3 c'est pas facile de défendre ce
pion si on ajoute aux rêves trois balles
à tour peut plus venir aider ses
camarades on quitte la première rangée
et puis en plus j'ai quatre où va la
tour et après il faut prendre trois
échecs
si on joue faux f2 bon ben c'est très
très passif
si on joue à eux quatre ça va pas parce
que on pourrait se recadre
on pourrait même prendre en d4 avec la
tour puisque en cas de non mais il ya un
cadeau rien du tout on peut pas faire
dans le programme si on en prend avec
échec
on peut aussi sur quatre fers fou échec
d'abord et puis après tout reprendre et
4 voire fou prend des quatre attaquants
la dame
donc ça va pas du tout et il resterait
encore à f2 bon ben on n'a pas trop je
sais pas si on a envie de jouer avec
deux donc faux et b4 tour un très joli
parce que tourner maintenant sur food et
2 encore une contre attaque et je peux
prendre à trois et je protège de 3
d'accord donc c'est une défense encore
une fois en direct mais qui en plus je
joue sur l' attaque
voilà et donc j'ai un oeil sur le pion à
trois que je maintenant je peux gober si
les noirs
ne le contrôle plus donc la fois 5
joli coup attaque la dame et on va
peut-être pouvoir prendre de pioncer 6
d'accord à regarder très joli coup
tannant damas six évidemment faut garder
le contrôle de la tour en en a six j'ai
un oeil sur la tour ici j'ai un oeil sur
le fou faut pas oublier que maintenant
le pion à 3 est en prise ça devient
chaud alors notamment je pense qu'un
coup comme fou fou des quatre seraient
serez sans doute perdant pour les pour
les noirs ici parce que l'afutt b4 le
problème regardez c'est que on a tout le
temps envie dans ce type de position de
faire d'en prendre dans prend et un
fameux tourbe évite donc là je sais pas
si un coup comme tourbains simplement
n'est pas suffisant que font les noirs
pas facile les contre attaques la base
de thora 5 qui sont possibles bon pas le
meilleur coup et on peut envisager aussi
à notre coût qui serait par exemple tour
des six pas tomber un meet our b6
davantage de tours b 6 si je laisse la
tour 1 sur le sur le pion oncle qui on
peut pas avancer créer des menaces et
j'ai toujours je vous rappelle ici que
j'ai un oeil là-dessus donc en cas de
toux reprend fou prend dans prend tout
reprend fou et bon ben j'ai quand une
tournette de plus ça va quand même ça va
être dur c'est même perdu mais là en
plus je menace d'un prend d'un prend
tourné huit clos âge et c'est fini ces
parties fines
d'accord donc il n'ya pas de n'y a pas
de solution donc sur damas si ce que
font que font les noirs parce qu'on peut
menacer à tour à trois qui menace aussi
fourbe et 4 on vient de le voir à cause
de tomber si ça marche pas donc apparu
du canard scène ben il le seul c'est
faux procès set et ça a l'air de marcher
puisque regarder fou prend fou bon tour
en tour prends ça me prend terminé le
pion est éliminée si je prends à trois
derrière mais j'ai rien gagné les quatre
contre quatre
et là j'ai envie de dire car ce n est
dans son élément parce que
on aurait deux îlots pour les blancs
seul pour les noirs ça va pas du tout
mais non on en a vu un coup plus loin
regardez magnifique évidemment la
pression continue d'exister
dams et 4 très joli très jolies dames c4
puisque la regarder simplement cette
batterie fait pression on peut pas
bouger puisque il ya tout reprend échec
voilà et là on comprend que ce fou c7 et
les il est complètement perdue il peut
plus bouger et la pression sur la
colonne c'est va décider de la partie
voilà c'est alors que là on peut on
pourrait faire si on sort la tour c
fouquet perdu si on sur le fou c'est la
tour qui est perdu donc il ya deux
clouage en fait
enfin il ya 2 il ya deux attaques fouet
tour on ramasse ce qui à ce qui existe
en ramasse tout ce qui existe sur la
colonne c'est donc là il faut et puis la
menace tout de suite cette princesse est
en plus donc il faut trouver une défense
immédiate
il y en a pas d'autre le 5 to 5 pourquoi
parce que je bouge bien sûr la diagonale
du fou j'ai pas d'autre choix fou prend
et la menace toujours pareil le fou
c'est celle de la prise la tour s'est
vite derrière car si on continue quand
même il a vu des petits trucs faut faire
attention
il sacrifie la qualité comme ça on
élimine l'attaquant de ses sept d'accord
déprend et là regardez il tente un
dernier truc dams est alors c'est un
joli coup puisque sa garde le contrôle
sur le pion à 3 et 1 sa menace regardez
bien d'en prendre 5
je garde un contrôle et attention
puisque je menace de venir faire un
chatouille ageeci chatouille age ii roi
sur la case sur la case h 2 donc
attention faut rester extrêmement
vigilant alors on pourrait envisager un
coup comme tour c'est un simplement pour
les blancs qu'à l'ère de gagner sauf que
bon tour c1 c'est quand même un tout
petit peu encore un peu punk chip à ce
qu'il faut on peut jouer à deux et
maintenant quatre prises dans ses sept
tours prend d'en prendre dans prend et
après tout reprend c'est le nord qui
gagne puisqu'ils font dame alors bien
sûr on peut prendre le pion à 2 par
exemple ici l'accord est sûr d'en
prendre 5 gr par contre on a des soucis
donc là la menace c'est de pardon la
menace ici c'est de rentrer en h2 et
aussi c'est d'armes prend 2,3 ici donc
il ya deux de menaces avec le fou ici
son âge 203 avec échec voilà donc c'est
quand même tout petit peu embêtant donc
et on en a vu un coup plus loin il va
pas laisser faire tout ça regardez ils
jouent un très joli coup aussi ce
magnifique superbe
ça suffit
que font les noir e 6 empêche d'un 3e 5
c'est ça l'idée c'est très simple
imaginons que les noirs face d'un prend
1,6 c'est envisageable parce qu'après
tout reprend 1,6 on pourrait se dire
fourrage deux échecs faut pas l'oublier
celui-là roi prend pour prendre mais
c'est aux blancs de jouer donc on va
faire échec tout reprend à trois une
tour de plus terminé
autre possibilité on prendrait avec le
pion aux 6 il faut faire attention ça ce
serait une faute
ton prend 1,6 c'est pas terrible
pourquoi parce qu'il ya toujours des
menaces
donc faudrait par exemple dames et 7 et
il ya attention il ya une menace fou
prend h2 avec échec donc c'est pas c'est
pas idéal et on a l'impression qu'on
peut du coup sauvegarder la torah
pressèrent que la menace si la dame joue
bien on peut enlever la tour de ceux de
ce courage désagréable et il ça reste à
gagner c'est bon il ya une qualité de
plus pour les blanches toujours mieux
mais c'est pas forcément le mieux autre
possibilité qu'on pourrait envisager
pour les pour les noirs ici par exemple
f5
j'essaie de créer des contre eux
menacent vague
bon c'est pas terrible terrible
simplement ici les blancs pour et
pilonnés sur la colonne s'est terminée
/ a2 toujours la même idée en cas de
prise prise d'un prend d'en prendre pour
prendre dame d'accord simplement on
prend alors des on peut toujours pas
bouger
le fou peut pas bouger sinon la tour est
perdu donc on peut pas s'en sortir après
aussi ce qu'arsène joue encore wife huit
tours c1
voilà j'ai appuyé d'accord à deux même
pas non payées pas à 2 pardon ça ça
finit à tour c'est un voile à tour ses
seins et abandon voilà car c'est ni
s'ils abandonnent dans cette position
c'est fini il va perdre le pion ses 7 ou
la tour c 8 au choix ou les deux et
c'est terminé
il n'a même pas alors on peut il y
aurait pu suivre par à deux mais on va
regarder ce qui se serait passé sur a2
toujours pareil on ne peut pas prendre
tout de suite parce que tout reprend
entreprend d'en prendre un point pour
prendre dames avec échec en plus mais
simplement si on fait simplement d'un
prend 1,2 et tout tient ici au point fr
on peut pas toujours pas bougé le fond
ni à tour si on bouge la tour on perd le
fou sinon on bouge le fou on perd la
tour voilà entre sacrifier le fou mais
dans ce cas là les blancs une tour de
plus c'est fini voilà donc c'est
magnifique
victoire d'un nombre incroyable
puisqu'on est la troisième partie allant
donc revient au score de façon
magnifique en jouant son style c'est à
dire une grande préparation de
l'ouverture milieu de jeu extrêmement
précis et il a évité la les
problématiques que pose car scène à
jouer des finales technique dans
laquelle il est dans lesquelles il se
démontre extrêmement fort là il n'a pas
pu il n'a pas pu s'en sortir il s'est
fait ligoter liés dès le début est en
préparation
c'est la première victoire d'un homme en
championnat du monde face à carsen
depuis le premier championnat du monde
il en avait gagné aucune la première il
s'était fait un peu écrasée est là et
bien il a réussi à passer le mur
et ça ça change tout le championnat du
monde est pleinement relancé voilà donc
ça nous promet une belle suite je vous
donne rendez vous pour la quatrième
partie qui s'annonce explosive avec
arsène et les blancs il aura les blancs
pour tenter de pourquoi pas de repasser
devant et on va voir ce que hollande a
préparé est-ce qu'il va rejouer la
berlinoise
alors qu'il a perdu ou est-ce qu'il a
quelque chose en réserve
on verra ça merci de m'avoir suivi sur
rodez bonal tv pour ce championnat du
monde de troisième partie et à bientôt
au revoir